انت قد تكون الضحيه التاليه لتقنيه افزعت
الكثيرين مؤخرا واخر ضحاياها ترامب
وماكرون وبوتين فعشرات ملايين المشاهدات
والتفاعلات ضجت بها السوشيال ميديا خلال
الايام الماضيه حول هذه الصور لكن كيف تم
تصميم هذه الصور المزيفه التي تبدو واقعيه
للغايه ما شاهدتموه صمم بواسطه برامج
مختصه تستخدم ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي
واشهر هذه البرامج متجرني الذي يعمل على
مبدا نرسم لك ما في خيالك ببساطه اكثر
وبعد الاشتراك بالبرنامج المتاح للجميع
يمكنك كتابه ما تريد عبر هذا البرنامج
ليصمم لك ما تطلبه خلال دقائق معدوده فقط
عبر خوارزميات معقده مرتبطه بالذكاء
الاصطناعي فمثلا لو طلبت منه صوره لطائر
يرتدي بدله رسميه
اجتماعا في الشركه ستكون الصوره هكذا او
ترامب يغني داخل السجن وغيرها الكثير من
الافكار والتصاميم لكن خطوره هذه التقنيه
كبيره جدا فهي تعد اداه فعاله لتشويه
السمعه ووسيله للابتزاز بالاموال والتلاعب
بالراي العام ورغم ان هناك العديد من
الابحاث التي تشير الى ان ما يصل الى 30%
من الناس ينخدعون بمثل هذه الصور الا ان
الخبراء يقولون انها سرعان ما تنكشف صوره
بوت هذه مثلا لو ركزت جيدا ستلاحظ ان حجم
راسه اكبر من جسده بكثير وهنا يد ترامب
تبدو قصيره وغير طبيعيه مع ذلك يقول
مختصون مع كل التطور الذي تشهده برامجه
تزييف الصور والفيديوهات هناك اخرون
يطورون برامج موازيه هدفها كشف الحقيقي من
المفبرك